good afternoon i'm lieutenant ray
spencer i'm the homicide lieutenant with
the las vegas metropolitan police
department
i'm out here this afternoon to brief you
on a homicide investigation that we are
conducting in the 1000 block of sierra
vista drive
which is in the central part of the
valley near maryland parkway in sahara
i stress the details that i'm sharing
right now are very preliminary but at
around 12 15
this afternoon officers responded on
report of two
children one at age one the other at two
months of age that were deceased in an
apartment directly behind me
officers arrived in attempted medical
aid on one of the children
however both children were deceased at
the scene
the mother of the child who is a black
female in her late 20s was taken into
custody
and she is currently being interviewed
by detectives at lvnpd headquarters
and will be booked for two counts of
open murder at this point
it's a very active and ongoing
investigation
with that i will take a couple questions
but i don't know how many answers i'm
going to have right now
on one of the oldest child we do not
know what exactly the cause of death is
going to be
on the younger child we have a very good
idea what the cause of injury is however
i'm not going to get into that right now
until after autopsy
uh the older child uh was officers
attempted to
render aid however at that point uh
medical got there
and the child was beyond uh help at that
point
who alerted him who alerted law
enforcement
the father of the child came home and
noticed that both
children were in a corner in the bed in
the living room
and went up to both children and noticed
that both children were cold
and were obviously deceased and that's
there was a conversation between him and
the mother
at that point he called 9-1-1 and police
arrived
their officers when they the father is
extremely upset
uh in the condition that he found both
of his children uh
i'll just leave it at that when officers
got here you know and he's still upset
it's a horrific scene that officers are
dealing with right now and the family
are dealing with
and that's probably what neighbors are
describing
how much time would have passed
we don't know right now again we're
still we're hours away before we can
actually examine the bodies with the
coroner
but again we still don't know i can tell
you that
when medical got here there was a
determination that both children were
well beyond
any medical intervention
it's still too early but i would
definitely not rule that out at this
point
you know officers definitely see a lot
uh especially in the terms of crime
when it deals with two children how does
that impact a lot of officers here he's
trying to investigate
i think it impacts everybody that's out
here on this scene right now uh be it
the
people in the courtyard that are dealing
with it the officers the detectives
myself
you know you're lying to yourself if you
don't say that this doesn't affect you
when you have two children
that are murdered inside an apartment by
their mother so
we have our employee assistance people
out here assisting our employees as well
as
our trauma intervention assisting the
family members that are out here
you're still working on a motive at this
time we don't i'm sorry not to cut you
off yes we do not know the motive we're
still speaking with her at this point
we are speaking with neighbors but
nothing has come out that any neighbors
or anything have heard
anything the first indication that
anything
was wrong was when the father returned
home and found both of his children
deceased
thank you guys